JUAN WILLIAMS, DANA PERINO,
JESSE WATTERS.
"THE FIVE."
AS DONALD TRUMP SIGNED YET
ANOTHER TRADE DEAL AND REVEALS
THE MIDDLE EAST PEACE PLAN AMID
AN ECONOMIC BOOM, IT RAISES THE
KEY QUESTION, HOW CAN A
PRESIDENT DO SO MANY AFFECTIVE
THINGS AND STILL FACE A HATEFUL
OPPOSITION?
PEOPLE GREAT HIS WORK BASED ON
THEIR LIVES.
THEY WILL TELL YOU THINGS ARE
GREAT BECAUSE THE RESULTS ARE
OBVIOUS.
MORE JOBS, HIGHER WAGES, BUT IF
YOU ASK HIM ABOUT IMPEACHMENT OR
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT IN GENERAL,
THE RESPONSES WILL VARY, SO WHAT
HAPPENS WHEN YOU SAY ANYTHING
NICE ABOUT TRUMP?
IF YOU RUB ME THE WRONG WAY FOR
TWO YEARS AGO MAYBE HE STILL
DOES.
BUT THE MEDIA RUNS THE TURF
WHERE FACTS AND OPINIONS CAN BE
MOLDED INTO ANY NARRATIVE THEY
DESIRE.
WE KNOW THE NARRATIVE, TRUMP IS
UNSTABLE, ABOUT TO CAUSE WORLD
WAR III, HE IS A RACIST, NOT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE ECONOMY.
ALL ARE BORN FROM EMOTION
DISCONNECTED FROM CONCRETE
RESULT.
YET LIKE A T-SHIRT CANON, THE
MEDIA CAN SHOOT THOSE MESSAGES
TO YOU AT HOME AND CALL IT AN
HONEST DAYS WORK.
IT’S SAFE TO SAY MUCH OF THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN TRUMP’S
RESULTS AND THE POLLS ARE
LARGELY MEDIA DRIVEN.
THE MEDIA IS LIKE THE BITTER
EX-SPOUSE WHISPERING BAD THINGS
TO THE KIDS ABOUT THE OTHER
PARENT AND IMPEACHMENT IS THE
WAY TO REALLY TAR THE GUY AND
THEY AREN’T REALLY HIDING IT.
IT SEEMS LIKE IMPEACHMENT
ALREADY REVS UP AND ALREADY
COMPETITIVE PRESIDENT.
HE ALREADY DOES MORE.
IF YOU KEEP HIM ACTIVE, HE WILL
PROBABLY CURE THE CORONAVIRUS
AND MAKE CHINA PAY FOR IT.
THAT MONOLOGUE WAS DEDICATED TO
YOU, IT WAS LIKE DEDICATING A
SONG, JUAN.
I THINK HE WOULD AGREE THAT THE
TRADE DEAL, THE PEACE PLAN, THE
TERRORISTS, IMPEACHMENT HAS MADE
TRUMP THE MOST EFFECTIVE
PRESIDENT IN OUR LIFETIMES.
>> Juan: REALLY?
FIRST ON THE CORONAVIRUS, I HAVE
HAD THE SNIFFLES LATELY AND IT’S
BEEN A GREAT CONCERN TODAY.
SO I WAS THINKING, IF HE CAN
REALLY SOLVE THE CORONAVIRUS,
GREG MAY HAVE SOMETHING.
>> Greg: NOW MAYBE I DON’T
WANT HIM TO DO.
I PUT EYE DROPS IN YOUR COFFEE.
>> Juan: OH, DON’T DO IT.
ANYWAY, I WOULD SAY THIS.
YOU COULD SAY, YES, I THINK THE
U.S. NCA IS A GOOD THING,
ESPECIALLY FOR OUR FARMERS, OUR
TRADE DEALS, THAT IS GOOD
STUFF.
I WOULD SAY IF HE REALLY HAD A
MIDEAST PEACE PLAN, I WOULD SAY
MARVELOUS!
THAT WOULD SOLVE SO MANY
PROBLEMS.
BUT THAT DOESN’T NEGATE THAT
WHAT HE DID WITH
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY AND THE
UKRAINE IS BAD.
IT’S LIKE SAYING, I’M A GOOD
PERSON BUT I ROBBED SOMEBODY.
IT DOESN’T WORK.
YOU CAN’T SAY TO THE JUDGE,
KATIE IS A WONDERFUL PARTNER,
BUT YOU KNOW, SHE JUST BE
SOMEONE IN THE HEAD.
>> Greg: YOUR ANALOGIES NEED
TO FIT.
>> Juan: WELL, NO, BECAUSE
WHAT WE HEARD TODAY WAS THIS
ARGUMENT WAS ABOUT ABUSE OF
POWER.
THE MOST AMAZING PART OF TODAY,
ALAN DERSHOWITZ SAYING, OH, YOU
KNOW WHAT, IF THE PRESIDENT
BELIEVES THAT HIS REELECTION IS
ON THE NATIONAL INTEREST, THEN
IT DOESN’T MATTER.
YOU CAN’T IMPEACH HIM ON THAT,
SO HE IS A KING.
ANYTHING, ANYTHING.
>> Greg: THAT IS TRUE IF YOU
BELIEVE YOU ARE AN EFFECTIVE
PLAYER.
BUT ABUSE OF POWER IS NOT QUITE
HERE BECAUSE IT IS VAGUE.
YOU CAN SAY THAT ABOUT ANY
POLICY YOU DON’T LIKE.
>> Dana: ABSOLUTELY, REMEMBER
WHEN PRESIDENT OBAMA SAID I
DON’T NEED YOU TO CONGRESS, I’VE
GOT A PEN AND A PHONE.
PEOPLE WERE LIKE, YOU CAN’T DO
THAT, YOU HAVE TO GO THROUGH THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS.
BUT NOBODY IMPEACH HIM OVER IT.
>> Greg: WE TRIED.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: I’M NOT MAKING A
DIRECT ANALOGY HERE, BUT I THINK
PHILBIN COME WITH A LAWYER FOR
THE PRESIDENT’S TEAM, HE’S
REALLY EFFECTIVE AT EXPLAINING
THINGS TO PEOPLE, AND WHEN HE
EMPHASIZES, YOU HAVE NOT
PROVEN THESE THINGS BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT, SO ANYONE WHO
HAS SERVED ON A JURY OR WATCHED
ONE ON TV, THAT IS THE STANDARD.
BEYOND A REASONABLE DOUBT AND
THEY HAVEN’T DONE THAT.
I ALSO THINK WITH THE NEWS
TODAY, THE SENATOR OF COLORADO
JUST SAID NO ON WITNESSES.
I THINK IT IS SAFE TO SAY BY
FRIDAY, MITCH McCONNELL WILL
HAVE THE VOTES.
THERE WILL BE NO WITNESSES AND
THE PRESIDENT WILL BE ACQUITTED.
>> Greg: I CONSIDER MYSELF A
LEGAL EXPERT FOR MY YEARS OF
WATCHING "LAW AND ORDER."
WERE ALL GOING TO THE
SUPER BOWL, I THOUGHT I WOULD GO
WITH THE SUPER BOWL ANALOGY, A
FOOTBALL ANALOGY.
WITH THIS NEW TRADE DEAL AND THE
PEACE DEAL, ISN’T DONALD TRUMP
LIKE EARL CAMPBELL?
HE CAN CROSS THE GOAL LINE
CARRYING PEOPLE IN.
REMEMBER EARL CAMPBELL?
HE WOULD RUN, AND PEOPLE WOULD
JUMP ON HIM AND HE WOULD JUST
MOVE FORWARD AND SCORE.
IT ISN’T TRUMP MORE EFFECTIVE
WHEN HE HAS RESISTANCE?
>> Jesse: THAT’S RIGHT AND WE
ARE THE OFFENSIVE LINEMAN
HELPING HIM PLOW THE FIELD,
RIGHT JUAN?
FAIR AND BALANCED.
NOW HERE’S THE THING ABOUT THIS
ANALOGY --
>> Juan: HERE IS THE THING.
>> Jesse: THAT WAS A JOKE.
THE DEFENSES THE ENTIRE MEDIA.
RELAX, JUST TELLING THE TRUTH
OVER HERE.
HERE’S WHAT I SEE GOING ON OVER
HERE, THE HATRED.
TRUMP IS BEATING THE DEMOCRATS
AT THEIR OWN GAME.
USUALLY YOU CAN TELL A
REPUBLICAN AND SAY YOU’RE ONLY
GOOD FOR WALL STREET AND YOU ARE
NOT GOOD FOR MAIN STREET.
FOR THE FIRST TIME IN A LONG
TIME, THIS PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
GOOD FOR BOTH AND THIS HAS BEEN
A BOTTOM UP RECOVERY.
NOT ONLY THAT, FOR THE WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN WAGES ARE UP BUT
ALSO FOR BLACKS AND HISPANICS.
THAT MAKES THE DEMOCRATS FURIOUS
THAT HE’S DOING WITH A PROMISE
TO DO FOR THREE DECADES AND
HAVEN’T BEEN ABLE TO DO, AND A
BUSINESSMAN COMES IN AND DOES IT
IN THREE YEARS SO THERE IS ALL
OUT ASSAULT ON HIM.
THE OTHER THING IS HE IS ON
TWITTER AND THE PRESS
CONFERENCES, WERE NOT USED TO
HAVING THE PRESIDENT BLUDGEONED
THE OPPOSITION SO FORCEFULLY AND
SO AGGRESSIVELY ON ALL SPECTRUMS
24 HOURS A DAY.
IT’S UNSETTLING TO A LOT OF
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE JUST AREN’T
USED TO IT, AND THIRD, I JUST
THINK HIS SPEAKING STYLE IS
JARRING FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE.
HE’S FROM QUEENS, HE IS BRASH
AND BLIND AND GETS RIGHT TO THE
POINT AND IS VERY POLITICALLY
INCORRECT.
IT’S UNNERVING TO HEAR THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
GO DIRECTLY AT PEOPLE LIKE THAT
AND JUST SHAKE THINGS DOWN TO
THE CORE.
AT THE END OF THE DAY, YOU’VE
MADE THIS ANALOGY AND I WILL
DOUBLE DOWN ON THAT, IF YOU HAVE
A PLATOON LEADER, YOU DON’T LIKE
HIM, BUT YOU RESPECT HIM, AND HE
KEEPS KILLING THE ENEMY.
OR YOU HAVE A CEO WHO IS ROBBING
YOU CRAZY, KEEPS YOU AT WORK
UNTIL 9:00 P.M. BUT THE EARNINGS
ARE FANTASTIC AND YOU’VE GOT A
GREAT BONUS.
OR WHAT ABOUT A FOOTBALL COACH?
HE’S YELLING AT YOU ALL THE
TIME, HE’S MAKING YOU RUN
STRENGTHS BUT YOU JUST WON THE
SUPER BOWL.
YOU DON’T HAVE TO LOVE THE GUY
TO RESPECT AND BECAUSE WINNING
IS MOST IMPORTANT.
>> Greg: KATIE, YOU USUALLY
GET YOUR FACTS STRAIGHT.
DANA BROUGHT UP THE FACT THAT
THERE WON’T BE ANY WITNESSES.
IS THAT A GOOD THING?
>> Katie: I THINK IT DEPENDS.
YOU CAN BE OPEN TO NEW WITNESSES
WHO WERE NOT PART OF THE HOUSE
PROCESS, BUT THE PROBLEM IS THE
HOUSE IS SENDING OVER A CASE
THAT DOESN’T HAVE EVERYTHING
DONE.
SO THE SENATE, THE QUESTION IS
IF YOU ARE A SENATOR HOW COULD
YOU VOTE AGAINST WITNESSES AT
THIS POINT KNOWING WHAT YOU KNOW
ABOUT JOHN BOLTON AND THE BOOK?
THE ANSWER IS BECAUSE THE SENATE
DOESN’T WANT TO HAVE A PRECEDENT
WHERE THE HOUSE CAN JUST SEND
OVER ANY KIND OF IMPEACHMENT
PROCESS WITHOUT DOING ALL OF THE
WORK.
AS THE ATTORNEY ARGUED TODAY FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE, THAT WOULD
ENABLE THE SENATE TO BECOME AN
INVESTIGATORY BODY.
IT WOULD THEN FORCE THEM TO BE
IMPEACHMENT FOREVER AS THE HOUSE
SENDS OVER PARTISAN IMPEACHMENT,
AND IT’S IMPORTANT TO POINT OUT
THAT THERE ARE TWO SETS OF
WITNESSES HERE.
THE HOUSE INTERVIEWED 17 PEOPLE.
THOSE PEOPLE’S TESTIMONY HAD
BEEN USED IN THE SENATE TRIAL ON
BOTH SIDES TO PROVE A POINT.
THERE’S NOBODY IN THE CLINTON
TRIAL WHO TESTIFIED IN THE HOUSE
AND THEN TESTIFIED IN THE SENATE
WHO WASN’T INTERVIEWED BEFORE
THE ARTICLES OF IMPEACHMENT AND
THE ENTIRE HOUSE CASE WAS SENT
TO THE SENATE.
I THINK SENATORS ARE LOOKING AT
IT AND SAYING, WE ARE NOT THE
HOUSE AND YOU NEED TO DO YOUR
JOB.
>> Juan: THE REBUTTAL CAME
FROM THE DEMOCRATS WHO SAID
THERE HAVE BEEN 15 IMPEACHMENTS
AND WITNESSES, IN ALL OF THEM,
INCLUDING IN ONE CASE, I THINK
THE JOHNSON CASE, LIKE 37 OF THE
40 HAD NOT TESTIFIED IN THE
HOUSE BUT TESTIFIED IN THE